hi there
it's day
62
it's saint patrick's day i've never i
got my green shirt on i have never
figured out why st patrick's day is so
popular in so many places
uh saint george is the patron saint of
england saint andrews the peyton's
patron saint of scotland and we don't
really celebrate those days
at least quite as universally as st
patrick's day
um
you know tomorrow i'm going to have an
hours conversation with jooheon i'm
going to record some of it just to show
you um i've really fallen off in my
korean i have to admit i went down to
san diego with my wife to play golf for
her birthday and then i've been
following this whole ukrainian
situation i'm still listening to more
russian
a little bit of ukrainian than to korean
um but i have been uh putting some
effort into um
kim yong-ha as i say to the podcast it's
very interesting
um took my uh son and his family off to
the airport last night so
his wife's mom has to look after the dog
and it's a it's a what is it a labrador
and uh some kind of a
spaniel i think so it needs to walk
twice a day so
i have to go in the afternoon and walk
the dog so it's been a busy day because
i played hockey this morning
and
normally we have
you know
basically
10 aside plus two goaltenders
but we only had five aside so we played
four on four hockey with one spare
uh that's a lot of work for an hour and
a half i was quite beat and then i had
to walk the dog for an hour a big strong
dog
so i'm quite tired but um
you know uh
one thing that's nice is i study
languages for fun i don't have any tests
so in a way tomorrow uh
meeting again with julian whom i haven't
spoken to for about three weeks or so
i have no idea how i'm going to do and i
don't care
uh it's not like preparing for a test
where you have to somehow work on those
structures or patterns that were taught
or covered in the previous chapters or
that vocabulary i'm not responsible for
anything i'm not responsible for the
vocabulary
that i
learned you know over the last little
while whatever whatever comes out comes
out
nice way to study i like that um
the other thing you know
i'm 68 gonna be 69 in october
so some people i'm sure who are young
who are 20 they think wow is that ever
old
let me tell you i don't feel old at all
um
you know play hockey uh whatever and i'm
lucky i guess in that sense that i have
no major health issues
um and the hockey group you know i was
just thinking about today is really a
very nice group of people they're all
between the ages of 65 and
72 really
uh there's some younger ones late 50s
we play hockey
uh one fellow
lost his wife to cancer
in fact a number have there have been
some people who have uh
had you know cancer or other
diseases both players or their wives
so this fellow uh lost his wife and then
he had an issue he was in the hospital
and so we got an email from one of the
guys who went to visit with him and
reported that he was in good spirits and
moved home in fact
and another guy had moved in with him
because he's alone had moved in with him
for a week just to help him out as he
came out of hospital
and then our guy was asked him if he
needed any food he said no because he's
got so much food that yet another person
had to lend him a refrigerator to store
all the food
so it's nice that i mean i have my
family i don't you know
rely on these other uh buddies uh so
much but it's nice to see that there is
this and there's a great spirit amongst
these guys some of whom have played
together for 30 or 40 years
so that's kind of nice
um
and yeah i enjoy my my language learning
i enjoy it because i do it for fun and i
don't think that i do worse than those
that are in programs where they're
required to
um
you know cram what they learned in the
last month in order to prepare for a an
exam
i can't wait till i
till i understand more of kim yoha
because he's talking about
uh you know venomous and ancient greece
and
you know french revolution and
literature and there's so much stuff
there i just get little snippets of
but i'm going out to do some more
so that's all you get today and tomorrow
unless i mess up on the technology
i should have a little korean
discussion with
with julion
bye for now